(muddled electronic clicks)
- Flash sonar is a way of,
seeing with sound.
(electric clicks)
You're esonifying the environment
with flashes of sound
that would be a bit like
illuminating the environment
with dim flashes of light.
When that sound encounters surfaces,
it reflects from those surfaces,
and returns to the listener impressions,
imprints, if you will, of those surfaces.
In a very real sense,
it is a way of seeing,
but it is an image that is constructed
from elements of sound.
(electronic static)
(electronic mumbling)
I speculate on how things
might have been different.
Gosh, you know, in some parallel universe,
maybe Daniel Kish didn't lose his vision
at the age of 13 months.
And who is he, and what is he doing?
He certainly isn't doing what I'm doing.
(flat electronic tones)
My parents did not see the blindness
as an overriding factor.
They definitely saw it as very secondary
to my development as a person.
(clicking)
They decided that I would need to grow up,
like other kids.
That I would need to be
exposed to the same freedoms,
and responsibilities, and
opportunities as other kids.
(cat purring)
In my earliest memories,
I'm already echolocating.
My earliest memories,
I'm already clicking.
(reversing vehicle beeping)
(soft clicking)
I was tree climbing at a very early age.
Trees, fences, walls.
Slides.
Anything that was climbable.
And I did run into things.
I mean, I probably ran into my first pole
when I was like, six.
You get distracted for a moment,
and you find yourself kissing a pole.
It's an emergency trip to the dentist,
and getting the teeth fixed,
and that sort of thing.
And now we know, by watching our students,
and by bat research and dolphin research,
we know that echolocating
with the environment,
using active signals such as clicking,
is an interactive process.
(slow electronic music)
(soft clicking)
It's like having a conversation
with the environment.
Every click is essentially
asking the question,
what are you and where are you?
(mechanical boom)
A fence, for example, will sound sparse,
whereas a wall will sound solid.
So, as you want more information,
you start to vary the
frequency of your clicks,
and the quality of the clicks.
So it becomes a kind
of language of inquiry
to gather information
from the environment.
Essentially, that's how flash sonar works.
(clicking)
Okay, so.
We'll just do this quick and easy.
Can you tell me which side?
(clicking)
- My left.
- Can you touch it?
Bing, thank you.
And,
now?
(clicking)
- My right.
- Okay, now localize where it is,
and then reach out and touch it.
There, whew!
Well done, beautiful.
(clicking)
Yep.
(synthetic click)
I love your power click, by the way.
- Oh, I had a habit of
doing that since I was six.
- That's awesome!
(synthetic click)
Okay, now look up,
and then kind of move to your right,
and see what you notice about this tree.
You may remember it visually,
but see what you can hear about this tree.
(clicking)
- It curves.
- It curves, yeah!
See if you can find where
they kind of come down,
there's a point where they kind of--
- The base, the base of the trunk.
- Yep.
- Like where it's all--
- Okay, oh, oh, right, you found it, yep.
What we try to do with
World Access for the Blind,
is help our students to
develop an environment
that supports their freedom.
And then one thing that
I often tell students,
and this is just sort of, (sighs)
I mean, everyone has their own style,
but you may find that if you
click a bit less frequently.
- (clicking) Yeah.
- You know, and let,
I like to say,
to let, to let yourself breathe between clicks.
- Okay.
- You may find that,
for one thing, you may
find your brain tires less,
because you can devote
more processing time
to each click.
- An overhang.
- More overhanging trees.
- I outta carry a machete next time.
- Yes.
I'm with you on that.
It isn't all just about
throwing skills at a student.
It's about facilitating the
development of a culture
that supports the
development of those skills.
(mechanical thrumming)
I am blind as a result of retinoblastoma,
which are retinal tumors,
and I lost my first eye at
the age of seven months,
and my second at the age of 13 months.
These are both prosthetic eyes.
(clicking)
(cat meowing)
Okay.
(cat mewing)
We have to remember that sighted children
have to learn to see.
You don't pop out of the
womb knowing how to see.
You pop out of the womb
with a predisposition to learning to see,
but that learning process
occurs through experience.
(click)
And it happened rather
quickly and rather naturally,
because sighted society supports,
sighted children to learn to see,
sighted children to
learn to use their senses
to govern their interaction
with their environment,
on their own terms.
For myself, the process was very similar,
and I don't remember it.
I developed my capacity to echolocate
and to find my way around the environment
as a fairly natural function
of being expected to do so,
and supported to do so,
and mostly people not getting in my way.
(dogs barking)
I have a cat that could
eat both of you for dinner.
(man laughing)
(clicking)
(dog barking)
And you, too, probably.
But looking back, I can say that,
while running into a pole,
is a drag.
Never being allowed to run into a pole
is a tragedy.
(birds singing)
(smooth resonant music)
'Cause what you're really talking about
is basic human freedom.
In most places, blind kids
aren't even given any kind
of cane training or mobility training
until they're seven,
eight, nine years old.
It's thought that a blind
child isn't responsible enough
to have this freedom, to be
able to make responsible use
of this freedom.
It's easier to guide them around,
it's easier to keep
them relatively passive.
Blind children kept inside,
out of the light of day,
out of society,
not allowed to mix, not allowed to mingle,
not allowed to be a part of things,
and maybe, we could argue that it's,
in their best interest, quote unquote,
but is it really?
Does it really come from that?
Or does it come, at least to some degree,
from our own discomforts,
which we can't reconcile?
(electronic clicking)
(Daniel clicking)
Oh, whoa.
Ah!
(clicking) Daniel Boone
said something like,
I've never been lost,
just momentarily confused.
We're sometimes programmed
to feel the bite
of anxiety before it's necessary.
Society often programs us to do that.
It programs us to be
afraid of the unknown.
It doesn't really help to
be afraid of the unknown
if you're blind.
And once you get over that fear,
you can pretty much master anything.
(clicking)
(soft dripping music)
(bright trilling music)
(ambient tone)